[Music]
hey what's up guys it's marquez from the
mkbhd channel back with another hd video
review today we're going to be taking a
look at a sigma lens for a canon eos
mount and this is the sigma 30
millimeter f 1.4 a really logical and
very nice upgrade to the current lens
i'm actually using on the t2i right now
which is a 50 millimeter f 1.8 so this
gives you a slightly wider angle which
is better more versatile for use indoors
and gives you a couple stops of extra
light at f 1.4 so without any further
ado let's get to take a look at the
sample footage and uh look at the lens
itself
[Music]
so one thing i really like about this
sigma lens is the accessories it comes
with you can see here it comes with a
pretty nice carrying case that you'd
usually have to get an l lens version of
a canon lens to get along with a lens
hood which you also have to get an l
lens to get canon doesn't give you these
and of course you also get the sigma 30
millimeter lens
in the time that i've had this lens it's
quickly become one of my favorites at 30
millimeters the focal length is just
right for crop sensor cameras because
that gives an equivalent of about 48
millimeters on the t2i and that's much
more workable indoors and the f 2.8
aperture is really really nice
especially for low light low iso shots
which i'll show you later basically the
most important difference between this
and the canon 28 millimeter f 1.8 is
that f 1.4 aperture wide open this lens
takes in a ton of light and you can get
a good look at that right here it's an
absolutely beautiful piece of glass and
not only is this glass really high
quality but the outside of the lens is
rubberized and of really high quality
too so the time i've had this lens i
feel like i've spent many money well and
i won't really have any problems with it
breaking so without any further ado
let's introduce the star of the show and
take a look at the test footage from the
1.8 aperture
[Music]
you